hello and welcome everyone to actinflab
this is active live stream number
21.1
and we're here with john boyk and
several other colleagues looking forward
to a discussion today
on this science-driven societal
transformation series
and project that we've been exploring
and
uh had several background sessions dot
zero one through dot zero four with john
and in the discussion today and next
week we're gonna be looking to draw out
some threads and include some new
perspectives and hear from the questions
that people may have
and for these
discussions we're going to be using the
same jamboards that we were using for
the discussions with just john and i
and we're gonna jump around the
jamboards we're gonna hear questions
from anyone who wants to ask live or in
uh the youtube chat
and we'll have fun so we'll just start
with introductions and then get a quick
little recap and off we go so i'm daniel
i'm a researcher in california and i'll
pass it first to alex
thanks hi everyone i'm alex
i'm a researcher in systems management
school in moscow russia and i pass it to
stephen
thank you hi i'm stephen i'm based in
toronto i do a lot of work with
participatory theatre and community
development
and i'm researching how
social topographies can be used across
scales
of community psychology and other
development practices
and i'm going to pass it over to lee
thanks stephen
uh i'm lee i'm a researcher based at the
university of york and
i'm studying systems transformation and
my supervisor is johan fazee who i think
you've drawn a little bit john in a
couple of these patients
i was
really really happy to uh find someone
else looking at systems transformation
and um active inference at the same time
but although i think you're a lot
further down the line than i am in
thinking about this so really look
forward to this session
cool well welcome john maybe you could
give an introduction and start things
off
uh sure thanks uh for having me and
thanks everybody for joining us
uh my name is john boyk i'm a courtesy
faculty at oregon state university and
the purpose of these talks
is to discuss the series of papers that
i just recently published in the journal
sustainability
the title is science driven societal
transformation parts one two and three
and if you would go we're going to do a
quick recap of some of the material that
we've discussed before we'll jump around
a little bit just to
catch some
main highlights and uh of course feel
free to jump in with any questions as we
go
so if you could turn to uh
jamboard one slide one yep you got it
okay good
so this just is the pictures of the
different papers
the links are done on the lower left so
in case anyone wants to check out the
papers
please do they're all open source
frequently freely available
and we're going to focus today we'll
jump around a little bit and capture the
main main topics but we're going to
focus on part three design today
all right slide
two please
and as as we go through this
if there's
more questions if someone wants more
materials all of the links are available
all the links to all the papers and some
other
materials are available at
my website for this project principled
societies project
and i might mention there's also a
interactive model there that you can
delete a framework which we'll talk
about
so you can see how the economic
simulation
goes uh slide five
or slide four excuse me
yes
so what is the what is the purpose of
this what is the what is the problem
that this this series is trying to solve
um the problem that faces
society or really human civilization is
a host of
very large so far intractable problems
including climate change biodiversity
laws poverty
uh income and wealth inequality you know
you know soil soil depletion groundwater
depletion pollution i mean there's it's
a long list of very serious
problems that we face so serious in fact
that it's not clear at this point
how civilization will fare in the coming
decades even in the coming years i mean
the world is armed right now the world
is armed to its teeth with nuclear
weapons
so uh you know
any moment things could go awry or
or
things could just deteriorate
rapidly as climate change and
biodiversity loss gain speed
so hopefully we will solve our problems
hopefully as societies um hopefully we
will improve quality of life and quality
of the environment
uh but that is the per that is what
we're shooting for in the series is
pathways to do just that
i i would like to point out that this
series is focused on transformation in
the sense of the novo design of
fundamentally new systems societal
systems
which i talk about six i believe
so economic systems legal systems
financial systems
governance systems things like that
so the the the problem is the major uh
constellation of problems that we face
uh globally and the proposed solution
solution is to view society as a
cognitive organism
and just like any organism it has a
intrinsic purpose
of maintaining achieving and maintaining
vitality
so how does it do that how does any
organism survive it learns it develops
it learns it acts
it learns from its actions
and and it adapts to new conditions as
necessary
this series is actually a an r d pro
proposal it's it's aimed at the
uh
the global scientific body and my hope
is to interest the scientific world in
this
in this problem of
how do you transform how how could we
build a better society what if we were
to if we were to create
any conceivable way to organize society
any conceivable
economic systems or governance systems
or
legal systems
educational systems what would be the
best in terms of
quality of life and quality of the
environment and long-term
sustainability i think that's a question
that science is now capable of
addressing
perhaps this is the first time in
history that science had the tools and
the skill and the background and the
computational power to address these
kinds of very very large questions but i
think that we can do it now
the whole r d program is is is is
described as a as a
partnership between the global
scientific community and local
communities so
the idea here is to test and to build
create and test new systems at the local
level in in cooperation with local
volunteer communities
[Music]
um
and i and i talk about implementing
those systems and implementing field
tests via a club model which we'll
discuss a little bit more
uh okay so that's a very quick overview
um maybe on to slide five but first uh
stephen with a question and then anyone
else who's raising their hands sure just
keep checking at the hands yeah go ahead
stephen
thank you yeah just uh one question i i
know she mentioned um
architecture so you've got the idea of
architecture and you've got
um
these different things that we have got
in the
constellation
and i wonder if you could speak a little
bit more to
the idea of architecture and
how that relates to architectures in the
brain or maybe distributed systems of
the brain you know yeah you know
the brain is what i'm thinking of when i
use the work architecture well a little
bit i mean people talk about computing
frameworks and computing architectures
too but i really had in mind the way the
brain
functions
and
maybe i should make that even more broad
because if if we
if
if if climate change and biodiversity
loss and these other major problems that
we face
are symptoms of a cognitive dysfunction
at the societal level i mean that's what
i would call it the societal dysfunction
cognitive dysfunction because we've
known about these problems for decades
you know with climate change we've known
about it for
more than 50 years
and yet we have it we've failed to
you know
adequately address the issues
um so i i would say that all of these
major problems are symptoms of
a cognitive problem
or symptoms of a cognitive dysfunction
and then the question becomes okay well
if we're not cognating correctly
what kinds of where do we look for
better models where do we look for ideas
of how we might cognate better and i
would say that in the world of biology
including the human brain there's just
you know a million
or
a large number of examples that we can
learn from
like how does nature compute how
nature's been at this for a very very
long time
and how does how does it work in nature
and maybe we can
uh align ourselves with the same program
the same process that's going on all
around us
and if we do then there's i would say
there's the chance of
building systems that are much more
effective
at uh at uh achieving the the uh
intrinsic
um you know our goal which is to achieve
and maintain vitality
uh far into the future yes stephen and
then
and i was just gonna sort of building on
that because with active inference one
thing that sometimes comes up in uh
you know is that rather than the brain
being like a computer per se
that is a distributed and actually now
maybe even not even functionally
specialized in certain regions but you
know it's more of a distributed system
of which you know we're not exactly sure
exactly how all old that works but it
with the idea of it being a dynamical
sort of prediction engine so i'm i'm
wondering how
that could
how much might that inform
where you go with this
yeah totally because uh i i we're using
the word brain but but even when i'm
thinking brain i'm thinking whole body
and bodies connected to each other
other bodies in society that
i in in part one of the series
the title is called world view and i try
to set up a context for all of this and
it's part of that context i i i you know
i point out that everything is
intelligent like every piece of life is
connected to every other piece of life
you know either strongly or weakly and
and the whole whole of life is
processing information i mean that's
essentially what life is doing is
processing information
taking reducing the uncertainty about
the past or about the future from the
past
so yes absolutely um you know we have
the four e's for example
uh and we have uh
uh distributed we have
like
in part three i use the analogy of um
between neurons and and individuals in a
society and so how do neurons associate
with other and disassociate with other
there's a kind of a compliment as to how
people associate and disassociate with
other with others in the in the process
of societal cognition
and so we have
connections
in the brain we have connections to our
bodies connections to our emotions
connections to our feet and fingertips
and connections to everything that is
happening around us in our in our
immediate environments connections to
each other and all of that plays a role
in cognition
okay so i'm not yeah so i'm talking
about
cognition in the large sense not in the
narrow sense and i'm certainly not
talking about a computer model that
tells everybody what to do that's that's
not at all what this is about
thanks sean lee and then anyone else who
raises their hand
um it was it's more of an observation
really um it's it's just when you were
saying that you were drawing on the
on the natural biological systems for
inspiration
kind of occurred to me that then what
you're doing is a kind of a a bio
mimicry
yes
but in
but you know building on stephen's point
it's not in the older sense of you know
the mind is computer but much more in
the kind of in your senses you know
biology at all levels being able to
cognite right
right absolutely
i think i read by but mr fuller he said
something one day that he said
i think i'm a process
not a thing
i'm paraphrasing there but that's right
it's like all of life is a process
an intelligent process
cool and and those and those uh just you
know i'll say it again but those ideas
really are new to science and and what
the
i mean you know the mainstream science
new to mainstream science in just the
last
two decades or something like that i
mean fairly recent concepts of
of uh complex systems that uh you know
cognitive systems
uh the interconnectedness of all things
the intelligence of all things trees
communicating with other trees through
you know through soil fungus and
all of these many of these ideas are
actually quite recent in the science
world
and a funny note on that is that
mainstream science is new in the social
cognition world the professionalization
of science
is a new
topic and a new genre and i really like
some of these points about distributed
systems we can think about distributed
systems within one level of analysis or
one system of interest like within the
ant colony it's a distributed system or
within the brain it's a distributed
system but once you start thinking about
brains
john you mentioned the 4e the extended
inactive embedded and cultured could be
more e adjectives but that brings out
the richness and says yes it's
distributed system amongst the neurons
in the brain
and then the brain is interfacing with
the body and the body with its niche and
the tools and the social affordances and
it's starting to sound like a lot of
topics that we've talked about on active
live streams
so it's so awesome to to see how
we're taking some threads from the past
and weaving them together and i hope
that we can draw this out how a
multi-scale distributed systems
perspective on cognition
coupled with a social transformation
agenda
and preference vectors representing
policy can get combined through active
inference into something that's applied
um right right how to act how to make
decisions under uncertainty that's what
all this all of this is about
as a as a counterpoint to some of that
or is a different view on some of what
we just talked about imagine if we can
look at how
our society treats individuals i mean we
can look at
extreme inequalities of wealth
and income
uh
different levels of access to healthcare
you know like there's there's all these
issues social issues that we face right
now
imagine if your brain acted that way
somehow you know with with different
neurons where some neurons were just
simply starved some neurons were
excluded from the computational process
some neurons were given very few
resources just barely enough to survive
and others had so many resources that
they were
they were like wasting their resources
because they had so much i mean imagine
how well the brain or how poorly the
brain might
function if that's the way neurons
interacted if that was the community if
if the community of neurons was anything
like the community of individuals in our
society we wouldn't be able to
make hardly any good decisions we'd be a
mess
and we are a mess it reminds me of
dennett's fame in the brain model
and uh the firing rates of neurons are
not identical some are firing many times
per second others fire
not even in a day perhaps
so there's there's a lot
of distributions in these complex
systems
and how do we think about the whole
distribution as an outcome of a complex
process rather than just trying to
identify some sort of an outlier or some
sort of single phenomena it's it's uh
not the leverage point that system
interventions will be effective at so
stephen
and then any other raised hands
this also ties in i think nicely with
the idea of post-normal science um the
idea that in the post-normal science
world where you in high levels of
uncertainty you have to make decisions
so covid is a
classic case right we didn't they had to
make choices in january february march
april even now and you don't have the
data right you don't know
and in the same way with active
inference the brain and
different parts of the body are making
action policy selections
as is
going to inform
action and that's not quite the normal
realm of where science is you're in this
but this is where we're going to be
going as we hit climate change and all
sorts of other complex questions so
uh
that also is quite an interesting tie-in
because um kristen i know if you know
but he did some modelling on kobit 19 as
well yeah he's got into that yeah john
maybe you could um unpack that in the
context of second order science which
you discussed in the papers
yeah or yeah or maybe i can just pass it
to lee and you can say
two words
yeah
i know i'm happy to um
so uh
the
the concept of second order science
really is is just that the the idea that
the scientists can't be separated from
the systems that they are studying so
really where that's kind of led to in
systems transformation research is is
that the only way that we can really
understand systems is by engaging with
them and and learning how to change them
ourselves so we can't kind of stand back
and just try and focus on epistemic
knowledge alone really and that also
implies this kind of second order
understanding of ourselves and how our
own cognitive systems work as part of
the systems that we are engaging with
and yeah that was a value-driven
value-driven science where the or the
scientist is part of the experiment with
the stakeholders
absolutely
while we have you here that paper by
faisy was was authored by a very large
number of people it seemed
and i can you just say if you know the
story behind that uh
uh well a little bit i think it was
authored before i started uh studying
with him but um there's
a transformation community really i
guess of researchers and i think it
probably came out of one of the
conferences
that's been going on so it's a it's sort
of the product of the of a discussion
between
many researchers which is the way that
they kind of prefer to write really so
again like moving away from this idea of
you know the single genius to let's kind
of gather and figure this stuff out
together
right
i i reference uh
paper uh
several times in my part number two so
uh
readers can see how that fits into the
bigger picture here and it's it's uh
funny that that idea that the product of
research is collaborative it's a call
and a phenotype it's a group phenotype
how well this paper is and how many
people cite it and how much impact it
have it's not going to be reduced back
down to a single person
and so
let's take that and then just like you
brought up lee the implications of of
learn by doing is that we have to infer
by acting basically
so then what does it mean for the
scientist who's all in on that to be
studying
climate change on a coast or the
conservation of a forest or sociology or
anthropology
um
very interesting questions that i hope
um a lot of different listeners can
see resonating with their own situation
so stephen and then any other raised
hands
i think just also building on the idea
of this distributed input is and in many
cases it may end up
a lot of the may end up that a lot of
the work is not in science anymore it's
like science informed development or
science informed or even science
informing a model and the model informs
practices which inform
the way that communities can get
involved and now the real agent is
actually the community and we're serving
them so this interesting
shift between
where science fits in and
um can change you know i think that's
quite interesting as well yeah you know
i could have i could have titled the
entire series science influenced the
transformation because that is the
concept i was going for i called it
science driven but the the the
my
my idea there was was similar
and also the historical perspective
which includes many world knowledge
traditions and hundreds and thousands of
years and multiple continents not just
the story of western academia
understanding that that has not been a
steady state there's no stationarity
with peer review again mainstream
science especially the um second half of
the 1900s and further
that's new so science is in
transformation and has always been in
dialogue
from 10 000 years ago
so now given the agency that we have and
who we are and our affordances our
preferences what's the move so we don't
have any sort of a locked in phase to
resist against that's not to say there's
not inertia but it is to say that
there's actually a lot of agility in the
system the question is what are the
leverage points
where we can actually make that impact
and how my active inference come into
play
um you know maybe since we're on the
topic maybe we can just switch to us
jump ahead to just a little bit if i can
find it
or you find the slide and then lee go
for it
go ahead lee just to pick up on your um
your point there daniel really i mean um
i've kind of been hesitant to say it
uh in the actual inference kind of you
know discord server in the like but i
see such a huge amount of emphasis on
active influence as it means to um
you know to create ai and to improve ai
and i can't help i mean
i really spent thinking about how can
this knowledge be used to improve
you know our own individual cognition
and societal cognition human cognition
really well there doesn't seem to be um
i mean maybe i'm just missing some of
the literature on that so if there is
any you know point me towards it but
then it really seems to be that you know
like the whole big assumption is you
know we got to put this stuff in ai
because that's where all the progress is
going to be
et cetera et cetera and then i kind of
wonder is that really a wise goal
i don't know
i think active inference and several
other paths so not exclusive to active
inference it re-thinks artificial part
of artificial intelligence because it's
part of our extended niche and so yes
there's been a lot of focus on applying
active inference to machine learning
into reinforcement learning those types
of areas
and then what we're
talking towards here
is the integration of natural and
artificial intelligence under a broader
extended cognitive systems scope so
humans in the loop or real-time
computers just like every stoplight or
every bank transaction is going to be
every tweet is going to be
designing those interfaces
so that
within each blanket
there's functional cognition not viewed
only from the outside in but as part of
a broader system and maybe we find out
that we had good enough artificial
intelligence so-called algorithms in
and that we just had to hook them up in
a different way
uh just like connecting different parts
of piping could give you an engine
that's more or less efficient maybe it
wasn't the case that we needed some sort
of scaling on a larger data set but we
needed a new way to combine sub
components which is what biology does as
well
so
[Music]
just a few more thoughts on that um
so
this the science world and and
particularly this this
cognitive cognitive framework or concept
of what is cognition i think can be
useful both at the societal level and at
the individual level i mean in the sense
that
if
science can help direct the attention of
the world to
to how how intelligence happens
all around us in nature all around us
every day
how you know how we evolve to
uh
to
you know
expand on the information process and
the information processing
the capacity for information processing
so
it helps it help in any you know it just
helps an individual to understand
a little better or have a different
perspective on
what am i doing what what is what am i
why am i here what am i doing why
why
am i
what am i
you know like to to a degree that these
this these new developments in cognitive
science can help to shed some light on
questions like that and at the same time
for a society like what are we doing
here together what what is our purpose
together
right and if you know your purpose
it's a lot easier to know where to go
next how to how to frame things in a way
that is
suitable for
your continued well-being
and it's a it's a bright line
in some senses between first and second
order science in the first order science
literature
there might be a lot of sort of
engineering type appeals to well we'll
make the society more efficient or
science and foreign policy will just
simply be better
and once we take that second order turn
we start to think
we're going to have increased clarity
about our values it's not going to be an
easy conversation we might need to
invent new ways of having the
conversation or formalizing our values
but we need some sort of path that's
going to bring us closer to clarity on
our values rather than obscuring it with
technical advances so stephen
john go ahead and then stephen i was
just going to say obscuring it with
technical
uh details but also obscuring it with
with
incompatibilities between what the
science world is saying and doing and
what say the governance world is saying
and doing or the economic world is
saying and doing obviously if all of
these systems are part of the cognitive
architecture you want them you want to
design them so that they are
integrated with each other so that the
signals
you know travel from one to the next
just as the signals in your body travel
from one
you know one system to the next system
yep stephen and i think this also ties
into
partly what this lab has been talking
about quite a lot in trying to enable
this possibility of making those
transitions without losing the rigor of
the modeling because the modeling is
seen as almost another way to get to
empirical data it's not just quite the
same as science but the challenge you
have as things unlike traditional
science going towards engineering you do
have this ability to embrace effects and
values but the challenge is how to stop
things getting
prematurely rarefied how it's so easy
things get rarified and suddenly
effectively you're just using another
word for system boundary and you're kind
of really doing the same paradigm work
with some different window dressing
right so it's really that's the
challenge i think to to and i don't
think anyone's quite managed to do that
yet but i think that's definitely
we're on the cusp this is this is
happening you know right now this this
struggle of
of what does it mean and how do we do it
and the premature ratification as you
said stephen
it's basically there's a a perfect
investing strategy you know if you had
the time machine you'd know exactly when
to buy the dip sell high
we don't have that we're moving forward
we don't have access to the future so
there's two kinds of confidence errors
there would be being overly confident so
too early
zoning in on a solution that's the
premature reification
and the other fallacy or the other side
of that perfect strategy
would be
waiting too long
and so somewhere between waiting too
long and acting too fast is
that trade-off space that we have from
so many different perspectives with not
just finding the value of explore versus
exploit that's gonna be best but
rethinking the explore and exploit
outcomes as part of a process that might
be doing something like balancing
epistemic and pragmatic value for
example in the free energy principle
so it's a really
awesome um conversation and john
continues
and altering how you measure fitness
relative to those two
those two
differences
well since we've been talking talking
about science the role of science in
this why don't we jump ahead to slide
two
uh or uh
germ board two slide sixteen if you
would yep
and while you oh okay that was fast and
uh well uh we get that rolling uh just
one more thought on second order versus
first order science
you know fizzy's paper is great really i
think an important one
but
it's nude i mean that's it's new to the
science world most of the science world
is very focused on what we would call
first order science where the scientist
is a part is is a is an observer of a
system not engaged with
transformation of that system or
achieving value driven goals in that
system
and uh first order science is fantastic
you know we learn we have learned a
tremendous amount of knowledge gained a
tremendous amount of knowledge from
first order science so
it is it is fantastic for what it is and
you know has to be continued uh
but in addition to that we can also
start to be thinking about what is
second order science how how can the
science world be engaged in a
value-driven effort towards
some better future
and uh i suspect that there are lots of
scientists who are frustrated
who are frustrated because they don't
know how to there's not an avenue for
them to participate in
in really jumping in to make this world
a better place
intelligent people look at our world and
they see the enormous stress that we're
under in this moment and
are fearful of the of the even larger
stress that's a that is likely about to
be flawless
so i i think that there might be a
tremendous amount of frustration in the
science world of how do we how do we
use our capacities
to actually
fundamentally make things better
as opposed to just passing off of you
know them you know
sort of
little trivializing it a bit here but
just passing off a recommendation to
some policy makers who then do whatever
they do and you know
the scientist is then out of the loop
so
i i i think that this is the time
for
second order science to flourish this is
the this is the opportunity for the
science community to really get engaged
in these
deep and important problems that
civilization faces right now
and in the in the in the series i'm i'm
trying to propose an r d program that
is a path for the science world to get
involved in these in these deeper
questions
and have an impact a deeper impact on
civilization
so this uh this slide is a is kind of a
summary of uh from my paper of of why
should science
you know why should science care about
this and why should science get involved
and we can just we can talk about any
number of these but i'll just sort of
jump through a little bit just to
highlight a few ideas
the very first one is just this idea of
societal cognition that's that's
you know that's kind of new that's
that's uh there's there's great
potential for scientific discovery just
on that question of how what does a
society cognate how does it cognate uh
in you know in what ways by what
mechanisms by what features
and what with what characteristics i
mean there's you know just as far as
expanding the level of knowledge this
question is really interesting
um a second one
so
we're talking about designing societal
systems and obviously this is a really
complex
issue these are not this is not a simple
how do you build a better can opener
right this is a this is difficult and
complex issues and the science world has
has skills that can be really useful in
in addressing these questions and
framing the framing the movement towards
how do we how do we start how do we test
what are the how do we measure fitness
how do we
what is the goal what is the purpose
what are we doing you know like the
science world would have a lot to say
about uh framing this entire
question of what is societal
transformation and how would we move how
would we move forward with it
i might add too
to this that
um
as i see it at least one of the benefits
of having the science world involved in
this question of societal transformation
is that the science world can provide
kind of object sort of objective and
consistent
metrics and frameworks to help guide the
process
that is
turned around uh if
if this if this if this process of
societal transformation this program of
societal transformation
was merely
based on
what a group
uh like you know the the
um
[Music]
this group votes for this let's do this
and this other group votes for let's do
this and it was just it was just a
popularity contest of whatever was most
popular in the moment that's where
that's where that's where the
transformation is going i don't think
the science world would have any much
interest in that like
popularity contests or that kind of uh
that kind of effort that where's the sun
you know where's the knowledge and that
where's the science
it would be on the other hand i think it
would be very interesting to the science
world if transformation was based on
some kind of principled approach some
kind of
some kind like we can agree uh to
to an extent at least we can agree what
fitness might mean for society
and some of that would be based on
objective measures some of it might be
based on subjective measures but
intelligent people can get together and
and conceptualize what fitness for a
society or for a societal system might
look like you know these are of course
complicated problems deep problems
but if we could do that as a community
if we could if we could
find some way to assess fitness in a
reasonable reasonable way a reasonably
coherent way a reasonably consistent way
then
then we have a path to to move forward
of you know different different groups
could try different ways to reach a high
fitness and all of those experiments
would be adding to the body of knowledge
of how do we do this so that fitness
improves right
i don't mean to to say that that coming
up with fitness scores and fitness
evaluations of new systems would be easy
but it isn't it is a topic that we can
tackle and it's because
that because of
our capacity to
conceptualize fitness and and
formalize fitness in the sense of a
formal assessment i think that makes the
whole proc i'm hoping that makes the
whole project interesting to the science
world because now we're now this is
science now this now this is expanding
knowledge this is using uh first
principles and you know scientific
principles to evaluate systems and and
it's not a popularity contest it's not
uh you know this is this is adding to
our understanding of of of how the world
works and how
intelligence works and how cognition
works you know and expanding it out to
the societal level
thanks i don't know i mean maybe there's
some thoughts on that alone but
yep stephen and then anyone else who
raises their hands
yeah just sort of a couple of questions
around that the idea of fitness
landscapes and how that might be used is
i sense you're you're sort of proposing
that you could use these kind of fitness
landscape i suppose you could even have
descent on free energy landscapes
to try and help inform
policy selection i.e maybe which
research streams you're going to go down
um because at the moment you know we're
kind of
either tied into
what the market says
or some other methods but this could
because this fitness maybe you could
separate out because i could see a
couple of different
ways you could look at that then is it
like an extra field of practice to
inform choosing the policy of which
research field to go down and which
avenues or is it also within the field
is it with the fields connecting to each
other i just wondered how that might be
you know it's all of those because
because everything that we do ought to
be serving our purpose you know i mean i
don't obviously there's great room for
play and you know and exploration and
all that kind of stuff i don't mean to
to uh to
make humans uh you know
two-dimensional or something
humans are complex organisms they have
complex needs and all of those needs
must be addressed right
but
but the fitness i s the concept of
fitness
i see that
i see that as permeating multiple levels
right because because yes we would want
to choose policies that help us and then
and then what does help mean what does
it mean how does it look if it helps us
what is what is that all about right so
in some sense if we just say i want to
help we're already thinking i want to
improve fitness somehow right
but not just policy
but even structural design of what how
what is a system what what what how do
how does society make decisions how do
we communicate what is our communication
systems how do we get input from
everyone into this process of decision
making you know
like like so across the board both in
the structural design of systems
and institutions
and uh
and
even to some degree um
uh uh
social norms right through education
systems like what kinds of social norms
help us
um and then obviously too than in policy
but then even in our individual lives
like it helps i think it might help
individuals to understand that
that
what we want is uh improved quality of
life lower uncertainty how can i make
decisions in my own life
that bring me the things that i that i
think might actually make me feel better
that actually might serve me
uh on a on a
even a superficial and deep level right
thanks john uh lee and then stephen
yeah uh just some um thoughts on on the
the fitness
metrics really so um and this kind of
goes to the
go to the point about the way that
scientists need to engage with local
communities because there's quite a lot
of work that's already starting in in
that area and a lot of it is um
it's based around this idea of place
so
scale has already been taken into
account and this this whole kind of
sense of the emerging bioregional
movement which just essentially means
you know aligning your political and
governance boundaries with the
boundaries of ecosystems
um
and that then naturally has the effect
of it
it partitions things in a way that's
meaningful to to local people
um and then you can start to ask them
you know like what is it that they value
within their place because they're
already kind of connected to it in a way
um uh and i mean
i suppose one thing for me is this idea
of metrics really versus counter factual
simulation because once you start
putting a metric on something you know
like you have a number and then you know
that's something that people can't
really care about whereas you know like
if they can imagine how their you know
their local river system for example uh
wouldn't be polluted by you know sewage
being released from the sewage works or
you know run off from them you know and
they could see you know that then has
this sort of the effect of um
you know of engaging people i think
more in in the
uh in the actions that we would need to
collaboratively take to make these kind
of things happen sure sure other
different people might react in
different ways to some people might be
more you know
really appreciate the modeling aspect
other people might just appreciate the
boots on the ground
local change aspect but i would say
there's room for all of that and uh the
bio regionalism
concepts are great i've been a fan for a
long time and who knows maybe in the
future we'll move more and more towards
that so that communities are really
localized in their environment and
and protecting their environment and all
that kind of stuff
that's great in in some ways in some
ways science has to catch up with
communities of change who have been
working on this for a long time these
these concepts and in other ways science
is already you know
pulling pulling communities
you know helping to save more there's
more there's more there's more we can do
there's a bigger picture we can serve
here
so it's a it'll be a give and take i
think between communities and
there's one more thing is the
bioregionalism idea is great and a lot
of work also has been done uh in
alternatives to gdp
so you know the metrics that are that
people are talking about about you know
considering education and longevity and
disease and all these other things as
as opposed to just a single gdp measure
of
societal quality
so there's lots of work being done on
multiple fields
and to speak to the metrics from an
active inference perspective
let's just say that we wanted a river
that was
uh unpolluted we wanted no toxins in the
river so our preference in the active
inference model would be that the river
is clean that'd be in our preference
vector now traditional reinforcement
learning would look at the level and it
would reinforce policies that reduce
pollution locally and then it would
forget policies that didn't locally
now the question is let's just say you
start decreasing it and all of a sudden
it starts creeping back up your
reinforcement learner is going to be
quite confused so an active inference
we can say that our metric
is actually our uncertainty around our
generative model of the river's
pollution so then
what actions can we take if our
uncertainty starts to get wider
how can we increase our precision
on our generative model of pollution and
then of course concordantly with our
values that it be unpolluted how can we
act to reduce our uncertainty
and so it's the reinforcement economic
maximization mindset pick the metric i
want everyone to read that's the metric
reading well no
the preference is that everyone can read
but the metric in active inference is
our uncertainty around our observations
and it's an extremely
subtle at first but eventually very
far-reaching way to think about these
systems and what fitness is because a
lot of times fitness metrics people are
going to be thinking right like gdp or
write like something that we want to see
but we can actually now tease apart
our preferences
from our affordances from our
uncertainty in our generative model and
several other features of active
inference scale-free models and that is
going to help us have a
multi-stakeholder conversation in a new
way that's great great great great great
great great thank you um
yeah i just add to that i totally i
totally agree with what
daniel just mentioned there because
it's not almost it's not an active
inference per se on its own but it's the
ability of active inference to be used
in this epistemic foraging way
and i think the point that was made
there about reinforcement learning which
we kind of think oh that's some machine
learning method but actually
reinforcement learning is the dominant
approach to development
it's like it's the way humans have
structured in a way their own thinking
it's not exactly reinforcement learning
such a bit but it's it's so constrained
and it's so goal driven um and the only
integrating way to overcome it and why
thatcher then started saying there is no
alternative is the market saying it
can't deal with the complexity beyond a
certain point so you have to offload it
to this market which again you get into
that kind of
just becomes whatever's the favorite of
the day
and
this gives us a way to get into this
nuanced complexity it gives us at least
the chance to go somewhere other routes
and plausibly deliver on that promise
you know i think that's really cool it's
right absolutely
to give like a spatial metaphor on
reinforcement learning versus active
inference it's like if there's a
mountain peak that we know that we want
to get to the reinforcement learner
would say okay the goal and the reward
is the elevation and so it can get
trapped on a local elevation peak but
then it might not take a step backwards
or down a few to get to the highest peak
but again if we do a trajectory of
policy inference
on getting to the top of a mountain
again of course as a preference that we
have for ourselves in the future we can
ask am i reducing my uncertainty about
how i'm going to get there when i'm
going to get there and the way that
we're going to do it together
with potentially a group of hikers who
have different capacities
instead of how are we going to get to
the top of a little null and then just
stake out so it's a different
conversation style steven yeah than
anyone else yeah and so building on that
is when you have that come into play
is the ability for the active inference
approaches like you're talking about
is
magnified greatly when you don't just
focus on the one person or the two
people who are like the agents of change
but you say well what about the local
people who have no idea about the goal
they have no ability to elevate they
have no ability to contribute to the
reinforcement learning but they know the
slopes they can tell me the history they
can tell me where people fell to their
death in the past or
where there's
you know all these and that then makes
the place made place-based
community-based contributions much more
plausible um as why they they enable the
scientists and other people to
do exactly what you're talking about
yeah
excellent uh just uh just to point out
um
so we're talking about reducing expected
uncertainty about the future right
think of all the ways that that
think of all the implications of that in
say
you know
design of systems or design of
institutions or actions of humans you
know facing some problem
right so we so one question that
immediately arises is do we have enough
information are we collecting the right
information at the right frequency to
even understand what's going on or to
reduce our uncertainty second is how
good are we at anticipating the future
are we do
can can we do that with some accuracy do
we know what's going to happen next we
have any idea what's going to happen
next how good or how good are our are
how good are our worldview concepts that
lead to anticipation of the future and
how good are our
you know computational models about
what's going to happen next
how good is our information information
sharing capacities how are we
communicating with each other are we
communicating the information between
groups and between individuals such that
we can understand what's going to happen
next and understand what our uncertainty
levels are
uh
you know like i can go on but there's
like this it seems like a simple
proposition at first and then you
realize that proposition has enormous
depth
it implies all kinds of things about how
a society might function and organize
itself
one one thought on the wisdom of crowds
and distributed computation there's a
famous example from early in
quantitative genetics where it was at a
world's fair and a crowd was asked you
know you put in a raffle ticket you can
predict how much some
cow uh weighs
and then the average of the estimates
was extremely accurate
although many individuals were of course
distantly off the mark
and a lot of people take that just um
straightforwardly as
existence of the wisdom of crowds but
there's a few pieces of that scenario
that really matter the first is that the
people attending may have had experience
they may have been working in
agricultural settings or have experience
with getting feedback on their
predictions and secondly the estimate
was a bit bounded it wasn't that the cow
was one pound or ten thousand pounds
there was a an estimator and then it was
still a cognitive diversity that
contributed to that estimate so you
couldn't just look at somebody who
overestimates that well get rid of that
guy he's wrong he's like that's
counterbalanced by someone on the other
side of that curve that's how we're
getting an estimate so
having a distributional and a community
perspective on decision making helps us
recognize and encourage and foster
diversity of opinion
and also structure a resilient community
so it's something that will be really
interesting to see how and where
these kinds of memes and ideas pop up
yeah absolutely um
valuing differences of opinion valuing
differences of perspective is one one
thing that you had said there i just
added just add something to that is
uh in our polarized society today we we
you know there's like liberals and
there's conservatives at least in the
u.s
and uh
they seem to be in two different
universes almost right but
liberal and conservative
at their best
is a little bit like
exploration versus exploitation you know
the the necessary balance for any
organism or for any decision-making
process to balance exploration of the
unknown and exploitation of what is
already known what is traditional what
what is our history what what do we know
works
uh you know like at their best liberal
and conservatives are both important
just as exploration and exploitation are
both important and problem solving
and they're relative just like left and
right
when you're spinning around and things
are changing
it's hard to say and that's why we can
pull back
to some real pillars
of biological systems instead of trying
to scaffold further and further into the
political or logistical ether
we can actually
return to our grounding as a biological
society so lee i saw
your hand raised or maybe i didn't or
stephen oh yeah stephen and then anyone
else who raised their hands
that was quite interesting we made that
point though about you know we'd look to
explore the unknown
and i think that in addition to that
um because that's from the perspective
of say the scientist or the person in
the kind of
the knowledge
um generating game so to speak that's
their profession or whatever
but there's also that exploring
the known but not knowing that it's
known the tacit the so this is where
communities can come in is like there's
there's like they i
realizing that some of that unknown is
participants in those environments
no
it just needs to be surfaced this is
where some of the work with the
environment side of the active inference
the niche and these topographies that
i'm quite interested in my side can come
in because now they're exploring and
revealing stuff
and
in a way which is networked and sort of
not just isolated as single stories or
experiences and fragmented so i i think
that connects with what you're saying
can you give one example of what you're
thinking
so one example we did a project around
water issues in rural
areas of northern maputo land in in
south africa and
so they had different areas of water
catchment so some people were getting
water from a lake but the lake had
hippos and you know crocodiles so it was
a bit challenging for them in different
ways and um so you've got these
different water catchment areas and it's
like
they had the lived experience of having
to go there having to get the water
having to boil it because if the water's
contaminated you've got to boil it and
there's other um what it means then if
you're then doing that if you've got
someone at home who's got hiv
on top of that so then you know so they
can't walk or they've got to have so all
these questions so what they would do is
they would create a fabric map the size
of the room about all their different
routes to water and then share the
stories from eight different or whatever
numbers of hot spots and then that
became the sort of landscape so in doing
so that that wasn't given the answers
but it was informing another process
maybe a week later which was looking for
innovations looking for options for new
approaches so that's one type of
way that you could like reveal something
from the local landscape which would
never have been available to an engineer
from their own knowledge yeah great
stuff great stuff
um so some of what you're talking about
is what is our narrative what is our
individual narrative and what is our
shared narrative
right like what what is our life what is
our experience of life and what does
what do i as an individual have what
what
knowledge and lived experience can i
offer to this group that would help the
group to eventually function better or
make better decisions right
so
that's a really interesting question to
me
for many reasons but one reason is
how
suppose we were to move forward with
this this whole project was moving
forward
how do we communicate with each other
richly how what the i would i would
argue that there is no system no
functional system right now
that a million people or 10 000 people
can richly communicate their lived
experience their their understanding of
life their understanding of how what
might happen if a b and c happen
i don't think we have
we're in need of tools to richly
communicate uh uh our you know
and
i mean we're needed tools yeah
so that's a immediate opportunity for
groups to get involved with is just at
just that little question of how would
we communicate and how would we how
would we
how would we make decisions together in
some kind of collaborative fashion
probably how do 10 000 people do that
once or a million people when you can't
all fit in a room
you know that's the question when you
can't all fit in a room to really
thoroughly discuss these issues and
listen to each other how do we do that
at scale
right so that is
and
i think there could be answers to that
that's not an impossible task that's a
really uh interesting and
doable task if we just put our minds to
it
it's but okay let's relate to regimes of
attention and active inference
perspectives on narratives which were
even our first active livestream number
one was on narrative active inference
because we think it's
crucial and if there's going to be a
social narrative like you had brought up
well that's something that is not just
sharded into a person's brain it's not a
holograph where it's the same in the
person's brain as it is at the social
level things that brains know that
neurons don't it's not like each neuron
is holding a little mini brain
it's actually that there is differences
amongst neurons or if you think about
like star wars or movie it's like each
character
doesn't know the whole omniscient scope
and so we're part of a bigger story
and so it's going to be
interesting to explore what will it feel
like as a person and what will it be
like experientially
with a personal narrative to be part of
a broader societal narrative but those
will not be the same thing
and the desire for those to be the same
thing will lead to system fragility in
many cases
so stephen and then any other comments
yeah i think that that that ability to
know certain things is is a very
important point and i think in active
inference something that i've
increasingly been looking at
is
we've got external states and we've got
hidden states okay in different ways so
there's
from the perspective of the generative
model of a say a water engineer there
will be more like there's hidden states
from everything right from everyone to
some extent okay as well as states that
we can engage in
um and
so there will be this question about how
do you engage the hidden states
in a landscape as well as the
external states of the regime of
attention and where can someone else
who's got a different lived experience
contribute to
opening up and maybe telling us where
they think the meaningful
aspects of their landscape are so that i
think that as well as modeling happening
from
our own computational models and being
able to maybe use some tools that we can
model through
participation in placements place
basically
absolutely absolutely so so this tool i
have in mind
it's uh it's
i want to have my voice heard i i have a
story that is that could be important to
others that could be important to any
particular situation that
or topic that society is trying to
decide upon and i would very much like
my voice to be heard and not just a yes
or no or not just to choose a b or c
way i would i have a rich experience
that i want to communicate
now
you know i another person sitting next
to me might have a model of water
quality or whatever the issue is and
they might have something to say about
what their model
implies
but all of those voices right should be
heard all of those voices should be part
of the cognitive process of a society so
so certainly data driven in you know
model formal models of this and that
sure that's great that's fantastic it's
an extension of our cognitive capacity
and at the same time
i'm
intelligent
and i'm you know i can do things a
computer can't
at least today you know i can do many
things a computer can't
so whatever process whatever
communication system and process that
develops out of this ought to be one
where every voice can be heard can be
registered can be incorporated into
this larger
really cognitive process you're talking
about you know it's like sharing and
we're discussing but that's a cognitive
process right for a group because it's
leading towards some better
understanding of the world
and you know improved decision making
about the world
john if i could uh you mentioned data
driven
so to again sort of distinguish and
contrast with how you're potentially
using data driven versus how it might be
uh implicitly used in other settings
data driven who's being driven us the
data are driving us and our policy oh
the policy is going to be data driven
okay well how about it's human driven
how about the policy and our affordances
and the data are like a car and we're
driving the car do we need a better car
does it have too many wheels where are
we driving who whose turn is it to drive
how are we choosing which music is being
played in our human driven car
not
how are we going to fit into a
data-driven human
mode and it's just interesting that
sometimes what is left unsaid
or unstated is where a lot of those
values get swept under the rug it's data
driven what else do you want to talk
about oh values okay well there's time
for values it's like there has to be
time for values but the data-driven
conversation makes it sound like it's
the beginning and the end
right right today yes yes and i think
that can be expanded greatly
um
right so that's that's when i use the
word richness that's a little bit of
what i'm trying to imply is the richness
of experience the richness of
perspectives the richness of of past
information that cannot that i as an
individual can bring to bear on this
issue whatever the issue is and then on
top of that what what does the data what
data do we have how frequent how
frequently do we collect it how what is
its quality how can it contribute to
this discussion
right so very much
this
it's not that the computer has to decide
what to do it's that human beings have
to decide you know what to do how to
given all this information what do we do
how do we frame this how do we frame our
problem how do we are we even looking at
the right problem are we look are we is
our focus too narrow are we you know or
do we need to broaden our focus to
understand better how all of these
different problems
so very much human and the human in the
center
computation
and to connect that to first and higher
order science and i'd be curious what
you think the first order project is
like build a bridge the second order
project is like
given what needs to happen is a bridge
the best solution or maybe we can go
about it a different way and the third
order is well what really needs to be
done here what do we value who are we
those types of third-order questions
which potentially even um are on an
escape trajectory from science because
we're not going to be looking to science
in a narrow sense for the answer to that
third order truly human question but we
do need to expand this discussion from
what is the best way to build the bridge
to
how are we going to go about
fulfilling transporting people from side
to side
or making a landmark for our city
there's different reasons why we might
want to build a bridge and people feel
like a cog in the machine
if they're just being instructed at the
first order
like do this right but when we're
including people in higher orders then
we're part of a multi-scale cognitive
system we're not just a quote cog in a
machine so
then anyone else
yeah i think this um i think it's a
really important point and for me it
touches on um
you know metzinger's uh transparency
opacity
kind of uh you know are we
do we understand the the beliefs and the
frames consciously that we're operating
out of so in the in the bridge metaphor
you know you might say
um you know at the third level the third
order
oh it's it's really about how are we
looking how you know what's the ontology
or the set of metaphors that we've even
coming at this system through and what
effect are they having in shaping
uh you know our well a how we perceive
it and be up then our actions towards it
so you know going right back to the
beginning of this discussion it was
quite interesting when stephen asked you
john about
architecture
you know and i'm kind of thinking is you
know is that um you know is that really
is that a metaphor you know the
architecture of the brain is that is
that a way of looking at a brain or is
it something you know this parallels the
discussions about markov blankets etc
etc you know like are these things that
we're imposing on systems or are they
things that are really there
um i think the architecture one is
really interesting because it kind of
comes from this you know whole
constructivist tradition and i mean i
wonder more whether it's not so much
whether it's about the right
you know the most accurate way of seeing
but what particular sets of affordances
does a model or a way of seeing offers
you know in the face of this particular
problem in this particular niche perhaps
so yeah interesting stuff
thank you lee
um john continue or stephen and then
john feel free to continue
yeah just one last piece i think that
this there's
some areas that
i'm trying to apply these isms now and
to sort of put some buckets i think the
social constructivism is is an important
one to think about maybe science in a
way kind of fits in there in a way as a
human pursuit
pragmatism i think is very well aligned
um with
the kind of
approach of active inference and this
approach here if you take pragmatism
from a you know a human not a humanistic
perspective
well from the third one which is an
ecological perspective so
or any ways of knowing as well not even
perspective so you can drop down into
ways of knowing perspectives
you know pragmatism social
constructivism and ecological
approaches and i think
that
nexus is is quite important
as as a sort of
way to hold some of these ideas
this is you know this is a fantastic
conversation and uh
and i would say that um
exactly the kind of conversation that
would be needed to
to move such a project forward it would
be conversations like this
you know between scientists within the
communities
between communities
and touching it on the all these
uh you know some some superficial and
some very deep and subtle
issues and questions
of
how do we what are we thinking how do we
do this how do we how do we measure
success what do we want what is our
purpose i mean you know we're just maybe
starting that conversation here amongst
us but
i would like to offer to the science
world that this could be we know
this could be a
function in the science world of uh you
know a pursuit of study a pursuit of
of uh attention
and uh if it were
i think that the you know the
i think that's all that's really
necessary actually is to put our minds
to this and intelligent people uh
communicating
amongst themselves and engaging the all
interested stakeholders could
definitely make progress in this in this
endeavor
so great great to watch
great to be part of
and
yeah john maybe
if you want to go to another slide but
that's leaves the question how do we in
our dot one video it's kind of an
opening the dot one is where we've had
our background with the dot zeros
we've hopefully read the papers and
digested them written comments written
thoughts to ourselves allowed that to
reverberate and then we open the doors
and we come together in a group
discussion for point one and we also say
hey the doors aren't closed more people
can join this conversation
whether it's next week for point two or
on a broader scale so i'm just wondering
whether you answer now or later who can
be included and how can they be included
in participating
right
well
a few words
um everyone is everyone is welcome in
this conversation uh
in in the in the world and communities
in different uh in different
different types of communities the
science community other communities i
mean this is this is a conversation for
all of us to be had
what do we want what is our purpose what
are we doing how can we how can we
improve
uh how can we reduce uncertainty uh you
know about essential variables you know
to put a check more technically
how to do that i don't know i i'm open
to suggestions of how we make the next
step but you know i sort of put out put
out what i could put out in this series
and i'm hoping that these conversations
might
uh lead to
some
actions that uh engage a larger and
larger sphere of of individuals
and organizations so i'm open if if
there's suggestions i'm open
um could you flip to uh let's see that
would be slide two
uh talk to slide eight
yep go for it
so
we've touched on all these ideas and i
thought maybe this might be a a good
moment to to talk about some of the
practical implications
when in our original uh discussions this
slide was coming after the
after paper one which was all about
world view and and
seeing
life as a cognitive process
and
seeing individuals as as overlapping
uh processes of information flow
and understanding that that when we talk
about
a a
community
improving its
its
quality of life and quality and
environment we're talking about an
extended individual an extended
community that really reaches all the
way to the biosphere ultimately right
we're all connected with other
individuals and all communities are
connected with other communities and all
of life is connected we're connected
with our local ecosystem and with this
new ecosystem so
[Music]
when i when i talk about uh vitality
i'm talking about the vitality of the
whole really that's our purpose is of
human we're intelligent we're humans are
very intelligent we can think a thousand
years into the future of what might
happen if we do something today
and and humans can use that capacity to
improve and uh reduce the uncertainty
you know of the whole
uh
quality of life can prove the quality of
the environment and biodiversity and all
that kind of stuff so uh with that kind
of theory uh theoretical aspects in the
past what are some of the practical
implications
like how how would we use any of that
information to actually think about
design for societal systems right
so um so this is a list of something
some items that we have talked about in
previous talks and even touched on today
and when we think about what does this
mean practically
i would like to focus that
to a different question really and that
is how do we how does any individual any
organism solve a problem like what is
necessary to solve a problem whether
you're a bacteria or you're a human's
community right
what do you do
and and on the left are i would say some
of the universal aspects of of cognition
uh for example you have to gather data i
mean you're the intelligent
being is processing information and
information means that some kind of data
or
uh
information has to come from the world
and then it can be processed it has to
remember for example
it has to anticipate the future forecast
the future with some accuracy in order
to survive if if i see a you know if a
lie if i see a lion in my path
uh i might want to accurately forecast
that if i don't get out of the way i
might be the lion's dinner right i mean
anticipation is central to cognition
so so we i've only talked about the
first three in the list there but
already let's we could talk about what
does that mean for a community then
so how does a community gather data for
example
and that might be
you know through sensors through
through
um
getting the input of others in the
community about some particular issue
um
requires remember like remembering
requires that that information be kept
in some kind of accessible
form some kind of repository of
information
uh
we can think already of ways that
society does the does these now we we
for example the census bureau
collects information uh
you know annually and
every 10 years collects various kinds of
information
there's there's financial
surveys done every few years
uh some of that information is put in
repositories that that at least
researchers can access for different
reasons
but how
you know how does that how would that
differ how do how does what we do today
how might that differ from
if we were really thinking of
communities as cognitive organisms
how might we improve on any of these
processes right
and i don't know if there's thoughts on
that but i can yeah yeah stephen stephen
go ahead yeah i mean one thing i think
that's interesting is this this actually
points as well though to an interesting
dilemma i don't know if it's a dilemma
but certainly a
challenge
in the sense that
um these artifacts and these artifacts
of knowledge that we have
they're kind of
we have the option in a community
setting to place them in our environment
because they aren't they can be
equilibrium
based artifacts so for instance if i
create a book and i put it on a shelf
it could be their hundred years right
and they'll come back and it's still a
book right
so you've got this ability for that kind
of storage now when i remember something
i i'm with active influence i'm
establishing this kind of
priors an update of priors
um this is
generated on these lower level
sensory flux
pieces of um
sensorum which i have at higher levels
potentially
started to
interpret as what you might call a
signal
but it you get into this interesting
question because it's it's like the
error is kind of the signal in active
inference although it's possibly at
higher levels of thinking
it gets a little bit different because
we've been talking about that with some
of the modelling but there's a there's
an interesting
question around as you scale out
where some of this sense
data in active inference is kind of held
in the kind of collective knowing of a
community
which knows how to interact for instance
with the artifacts
yet you've also got aspects a bit like
i've got my clothes and i've got other
things that kind of they part of me are
they not part of me they're part of the
environment you you there's i think
there's something quite interesting and
i i think that's an area i'm really
interested in exploring is
is teasing that out so i wonder what
your thoughts are on that
uh
well part of part of
i think part of what you're
speaking about might be what i've been
calling richness of information right so
so obviously a a census can collect
information once a year about you know
numbers and
education levels and things like that
that's one that's one stream of
information a valid stream of
information and yet another is very
personal it's what it what is your gut
you know what is your gut telling you
about this situation or this
you know this this constellation of
what's happening today what is your gut
feeling
of what's happening right so how does
the how does a community get you know
process uh sense and process
all of that information together if you
have a you know if we're if we're part
of the community and we're trying to
decide on some issue
it would be good if we heard your gut
you what is your gut telling you about
this is this good or bad or should is
this direction good or bad or you know
even if even if there's no
like data data to back it up what is
your sense
based on you know the the the your your
complexity your wholeness your
like we can't even put a word on it what
you what you are or where that
information comes from maybe but what is
this what is the sense that you're
having and i would like to share my
sentence too
and everyone maybe could share their
sense so how do we how do we do that in
how do we do that when there's a hundred
thousand of us how do we do that
well
yeah
uh to give just a few thoughts there's
there's two sides to the conversation
they're sharing communicating and then
there's really engaging and listening
which is part of the idea of attention
topic so 100 000 people speaking over
each other is zero conversation that's
not yeah yeah that's not conversation
right exactly so how do we how do we do
that
and and i don't think that that's not
you know like it's almost surprising in
a way that
that we we have such enormous technical
capacity in today's society to do
unbelievable things
and yet this very basic question of how
do we as a community of say 10 000 or
100 000
how do we richly share information in a
way that all of us feels heard
that that are that we can express our
our
our kind of like hard knowledge and gut
knowledge
how do we participate together in
describing our situation describing our
fears describing our uncertainty
anticipating what is going to happen
next if we take choice a b or c
you know you it's kind of interesting
that that that that
that tool
doesn't exist
in spite of our technological process
and there might be reasons why that i
mean there might be political reasons
and economic reasons why that tool
doesn't exist because if that tool did
exist
people would want to
participate you know like naturally i
want my story heard i want i want my
community to understand what i know
because maybe it's going to help
somebody
and and i want to hear what what
you know in a in a healthy conversation
in a healthy exchange i really want to
know what you're thinking
and i want to i want to
contextualize all this information in
light of
what our purpose is what our goal is
what are we after what do we want
right
yeah
well can i comment on that because i
think this is a really important point
and and also though as well as see
this is what i find i'm i'm recasting
speech as an action policy
as an extended cognition into a spatial
landscape of semantics right so
effectively it's
actually words could be seen as in a
virtual environment that we're
projecting out and what that can kind of
open up is
that
when
i'm talking to someone and being heard
right which basically means
being
words are being heard right
so but there's there's certain things
that
i can't communicate through words
because they're not in that semantic
landscape which is the compression of my
a useful tool but the thing with tools
is
generally speaking it's not very healthy
to relate to tools right it's like tools
of things
so one non-verbal work can be really
powerful we actually had that with our
work within the community who use
alternative communication you know we've
really pushed that so they it can take
them three minutes to do three words
because if they're using the head switch
and they have to scan through each
letter and then hit the head switch and
then
so we'll really about how about it not
being about the words and about being
the look of the eye
and that
building up of
non-verbal
knowing between people which at some
point
will probably be well we actually then
articulate that through fabric
landscapes so then they start painting
the room and do world building and then
you start making the words so there's
there's something about um like you said
there may be something that taught well
we need we need the tools but also
sometimes tools just can't go there so
what do we do where we don't use tools
um and then when do we bring it into a
tool-based environment i think this is a
good point yeah yeah yeah
and i think much of human communication
actually happens non-verbally too if we
can be in the same room and i'm watching
your
facial expressions i'm getting a lot
more information about you and your
intent than if we if i was only hearing
your voice if i was only reading your
words so
sure there's there's nonverbal
communication there's artistic
expression there's
there's poetic expression you know using
words in a different way
uh
and
obviously we again we as an individual i
want to be heard and if i'm maybe i'm
expressing myself in words maybe i'm
expressing myself in my how i'm raising
my eyebrows or maybe i'm express maybe i
don't even have words to express myself
but i have an image in my head that i
want to communicate somehow somehow we
we have to be able to communicate richly
uh
in
in mass
and how do we do that and part of the
answer to that might be we communicate
in smaller groups
and that information then is is sort of
propagated up the hierarchy or something
maybe i mean you know the the the the
slate is wide open here so this is the
question to the world
how can we communicate richly in mass
such that our purpose might be fulfilled
you know our our purpose of of
maintaining achieving and maintaining
uh vitality into the future
right so that's the big picture and then
how what are the what are the what are
the many tools or
social norms or
educational processes or
you know
any number of things that lead us to
fulfilling our purpose
you know our intrinsic purpose i should
say you know our biological purpose in a
sense
nice john i hope that
people clip that out or hear your
question and really consider it and what
it makes me think about on this slide
and to return it to active inference
again
is really like the rhetoric
of participation because in a
reward maximization culture
things like communicate it's like but
not now we have decisions to make
whereas when we reframe about reducing
uncertainty on a multi-scale so
individual and shared generative models
it's like
have we communicated enough to even know
each other's generative model because
once i know that your generative model
includes this dietary restriction
i don't need 100 text messages a day i
actually can generate recipes that are
going to be compatible with you so it's
not like we just need to have more
communication or a different kind or
these two people need to talk or some
sort of secret trick it's actually that
we can balance a lot of these sometimes
locally contradictory needs
like
um
choose two and you can find a situation
where they align on this list and you
could find a situation or imagine a
situation where they diverge and the
power comes from being able to have that
goal directness and the epistemic gain
and then potentially through peer
mentorship or through extended cognitive
architecture we could be able to mark
you know where is there a yellow flag
where is there a red flag where do we
need to pull back
and share more
um about one person's generative model
or
how are we working as part of an
integrated unit
that's reducing uncertainty given the
preference vector
rather than
well if we each just make as much money
as possible then the group will have as
much money as possible right
so this is a different way that we can
go about having that conversation and as
hopefully we're drawing out
it's something where everyone's
perspective uh isn't just a uh
group to be formed their perspective is
their contribution and their value yep
yeah good good
we can also look to biology too how does
how does uh the cells of a body
make decisions you know like how does a
liver know what to do and when when to
act
how does the heartbeat know when to
speed up or slow down
there's rich communication that happens
multi-scale
some local some distant through hormones
through messengers there's enormously
rich communication that happens between
tissues and cells in order for all the
pieces to
understand what the you know what what
what is necessary now
right so i mean there's we can we can
this is an open question it's a clean
slate there's a there's a great
potential for the science world and
other communities to move forward of
this question of how do we richly
communicate and make decisions together
how do we do that
and uh and there's lots of biological uh
examples for us to look at to gain
inspiration from
so a question a question from the chat
just before stephen
um from yvonne
uh just about the tools
uh
how many people have used the kinds of
tools that you're suggesting or it
sounded like you suggested that it
didn't exist but what is the preferred
field for a startup from yvonne where
does this tools where is this coming out
of this sort of tool for communication
and
collaboration sure i understand the
question exactly where is it coming from
he asked what is the preferred field to
make a startup in
for this kind of a tool
like would it be
in the field of industrial engineering
or oh
[Music]
so i have
ideas in my head of how we might you
know start to build such tools
um
and
the you know the reason i'm thinking
about it is for this very
this very problem of how to communicate
how do communities communicate how if
this club model were to if we were to
move forward with uh
with studying this club model and
eventually developing a field trial with
a club model how does communication
happen within that club model so that's
that's my interest you know is the
application to this problem of societal
transformation and
and demonstrating new ways of of
cognition at the local level
via clubs
but obviously if you had a tool that
could do this there would be tremendous
opportunities for others to to use the
tool too
this is just one example of
you know thousands you might think of
but
um i used i work in the utility industry
and i've seen how messages get
transferred from you know a caller calls
in and says you know there was a there's
a there's an accident there's a wire
down there's sparks flying there's
children around you know there's some
kind of rich situation happening that
others need to know about
and by the time that message gets to the
person in the field or in the truck uh
you know it might be quite garbled it
might be
it might be not unclear at all what the
problem is or what the dangers are or
what the situation is right so that
would just be one example of how
industry might use a tool for better
communication
uh
and and
you know there would be many many more
examples you could think of so i would
my guess would be that if the science
community moved forward with this
problem of how do you richly communicate
with a large group
that
those tools and the concepts that would
come out of that could be applicable to
a to a wide variety of industries and to
this particular question of how does the
club model work and how do how do
communities cognite
thank you john stephen and then anyone
else with raised hands
yeah thanks i suppose this sort of
reminds me of some of the
principles actually systemic coaching
can be an interesting area like looking
at coaching groups that and the system
it seems to be that
um and i was just wondering if you've
encountered um
the viable systems model stafford beers
viable systems model because i think
that some of the active inference work
can recast that you know because you've
got not just
levels of
regulation on the on the body because
it's based on the i think it's the body
on the nervous system of a frog
um or um
or different nervous systems but
that doesn't necessarily have that
bottom-up teleology that you get from
active inference doesn't it so you have
the kind of the idea that the lower
levels also know something it tends to
be the higher levels of regulating the
lower level so
but uh hey that might be something to
look at as one area that'd be
interesting and
um yeah i just thought i'd mention that
in case you know no no great uh and uh
um
you know those are the kinds of ideas
that would you would want to explore as
you build the kind of tools we've been
discussing and on that on that topic
the goal is not to build one tool that
does all of this right we could have
many tools we could you know different
groups could explore a variety of
approaches and tools and
and uh you know
some depths of simplicity and complexity
and you know there's room for
room for
many discussions on on this topic right
um one other just just to kind of
continue with you the idea of coaching
i've been
i've been around enough folks in my life
to realize that some groups and some
people
are really
skilled at communicating and talking
with others and you know getting
facilitating group conversation and
things like that and and
many times i've been just so impressed
with the ability of certain groups or
certain individuals to
to kind of facilitate communication and
and show by example what healthy
communication looks like
and uh and and at the same time i watch
tv of you know i've seen tv shows of
terrible examples of how to communicate
uh you know examples of dishonesty
examples of manipulation examples of
holding back examples of
of confusion
you know examples of shallow
shallow thinking and
uh you know social norms part of this
whole process would also be to do like
the club model it would be to develop
social norms that are useful for the
community right that are reinforced to
healthy healthy behaviors or healthy
ways of communicating health healthy
skill development
that would help the community to better
process the information it has right so
so that kind of coaching is available
too
and this is something in the narrative
as active inference we talked about when
we see representations of communication
like they are
up weighted or our priors are updated to
think that those types of communication
are more likely or that they're
prevalent or even that they exist at all
and then we fulfill that prediction by
reducing our uncertainty about our own
behavior and our own thinking through
other minds of other people's behavior
thinking well what happens when there's
two people and they need to is they want
the cuts in front and then you're not
surprised when they do it you're not
surprised when you do it
but there's also a way to show
representations of that not happening so
that it will not surprise either person
when they both slow down
and that shows how our inter-subjective
level of computation is something that
is influenced by both the bottom up you
know the sensory input and the top down
with our cultural scaffolding
and so
systems in change
need to be able to resonate from the
small to the large
or there's going to be some um
pathologies so stephen and then any
other comments
so this actually could be an interesting
or could inform anyway the types of
questions that could compose to carl
fristen himself you know around some of
these practical implications so we could
have these in mind so i was just
thinking you know do you have sort of
i wonder if you actually have thoughts
about oh
are there holes in this or are there
questions around
where this
whole field of active inference is sort
of going in the sort of global sense and
and whether you've thought oh i wonder
what
carl fiston would think about that
anyway it's just just a question to put
out
carl if you're listening
feel free to
to join in
no i would love to i would love to you
know we
one of the many ways to start this whole
process off would be to have a
conference where we get together some
folks who have experience in these
fields in a variety of fields who could
offer their thoughts and
cautions and encouragements
whatever they may be well well john um
on june 21st 2021
carl firsten will be joining us for a
little symposium and in another sense we
have a nano symposium
every week but any type of logistics or
organization that are the enabling
architecture is what active lab is there
for
great fantastic
fantastic
um fantastic you know i maybe should say
too we've been talking about active
inference and obviously all of us are
interested in that topic but but you
know it could be that the active
inference 2.0 is called something else
it goes you know like we learn something
in the next decade or whatever and
active inference is no longer
you know like we've moved beyond that
and now we're talking about
some other thing you know what the the
important
aspect of this for us is how does
cognition happen how does
you know how how
biological organisms uh structure
themselves and orient themselves and
organize themselves in order to process
information and you know how does that
work
so whether it's active inference or
whether it's
you know something else
sure everything evolves we learn as we
go so it might be you know next year it
might be a different word
but the concept is how do we
achieve and maintain vitality into the
future you know that's how do we fulfill
our purpose and even today for different
non-english human languages and for
computer languages the word is already
not active inference and so that's why
it's always so rewarding and valuable to
be very clear on what active inference
is which parts are drawing from bayesian
statistics from complex systems from
predictive processing from all of these
other areas instead of thinking that we
need to reinvent the wheel because we
certainly don't we're also just a part
of the cognitive architecture and uh
it'll be a quite interesting ride for
sure so maybe in the last 15 minutes of
this point one john
help us uh via another slide or by
raising another salient question what
can we as listeners and participants
think about in this next week
to um kind of simmer during this week
between our two sessions
okay um
maybe next week we will talk we'll talk
more about you know we've we've only
covered two slides here we had i think
like 60 slides we could have looked at
we covered two of them remember maybe
three of them
uh but the the uh
the
the goal here was to talk about part
three of the paper which is design
so i think maybe for our listeners maybe
the question of like how would you
actually do this what would
i in parts in part three i
i
spent some time talking about a a
prototype called the what i call the
leader framework local economic direct
democracy association framework and the
emphasis there it is the the concept is
a full integrated systems approach but
the emphasis in the simulation trial
that i published is on economics so just
take that alone what would
what would a fundamentally different
economic system look like how would it
function and how how could it apply to a
club model you know like implemented at
the local level what what what did that
look like
and when i say economic i mean economic
slash financial slash monetary
uh institutional you know like all of
those things wrapped up into the word
economic
what how
how would that look
what are the possibilities
right
we'll go there next maybe great question
one thought is um econ eco
and uh ecosystem and economy it's like
they start with the first three letters
they're so close they're almost on the
right track with an ecological
perspective on economics yet you add one
more letter and it changes from uh
ecology to economics and all of a sudden
it's like never the twain shall meet so
it's an awesome question to be
rethinking how these different
intertwined systems relate just like
intertwined systems in an ecosystem of
like primary producers prey animals
predators renewal etc
right right so so on that you know just
to follow that up just a little more
what is an economic system
you know before we go about designing
new ones what what is the purpose of an
economic system
we ought to ask that question first
before we jump into potential designs
right so what is what what is it
supposed to achieve in the first place
and the i think for some listeners or
for you know the general population at
least if you ask that question the
answer would be like duh an economic
system is about to
you know allocating resources back and
forth you know choosing who gets what
and
and how resources are used
but i would argue that that's not at all
with an economic system you know like
like intrinsically potentially what an
economic system is i would say an
economic system is exactly what we've
been talking about so far today it is it
is a cognitive system it is a it is a
different variety of cognitive system
that allows a community to
cognate in a slightly different way like
a governance system allows its community
to cognate in one way legal system
allows a community to cognate in a
different way and an economic system
allows it to cognate in a different way
so if so if the goal is
functional societal cognition
what does an economic system look like
what one thought on that and using the
bodies intertwined signaling systems
like neurological chemical etc from the
point of view of the ribosome the
protein translating machinery insulin is
just another peptide it's just linking
the amino acids together and it's making
a protein but to the point of view of a
receptor the insulin molecule is in
affordance for binding and then to the
point of view of the downstream
signaling cascades inside the cell we
start to see semantics enter into the
picture and then there's a turnover for
the insulin and there's lactate being
shuttled from the muscles which are
using it and they're they're calling out
for help through these different
mechanisms so it's like
a cargo ship might be carrying
something
and it's putting it in a box and it's
just moving it like an encrypted message
it's just moving the information it
doesn't need the semantics to be able to
relay the information and similarly when
there's these intertwining systems it's
like that one insulin peptide can be
handled by a producer by a transporter
by a
signal detector by a degrading enzyme
and the idea that all of those pieces
are uh
you know you could just change one out
or you could remove one it wouldn't be
the same system as a whole
so stephen and then any other thoughts
i like the hormone um
reference um
as i think that
the the nature of the hormone system
where you you know the hormone gets
released into the blood
let's say the blood and it travels
around the body
it is actually maybe closer to this idea
of a message passing kind of
signal going out there you know
sort of sense in sort of a general way
which is and maybe this is something
that the economic
system does right is
and you can't do that so easily through
necessarily just
dynamical processes with people right
it's like okay you can you can kind of
infer things you can sort of build
things up but okay you set up a pipeline
of value distribution
or at least the information in relation
to value distribution and how that can
be processed and you can release
your hormones which is basically money
or
budgetary
predictions into that
system and it flows right it flows
around it and it gets picked up and it
becomes more like a traditional signal
that can be computed
and but you can't put out the dynamical
system information because it
it's not a thing
it's done it is dynamical so there's
something interesting there i think
around that that that analogy to
that
it's the system it's the system we're
working with to be able to explore how
message passing algorithms
instrumentally used by us as curious and
motivated investigators
allow us to act in the world to reduce
our uncertainty about blood sugar
so following on that the question two
for the public is what is money
you know like in its best sense what is
money
so
we'll try it we'll try to tackle some of
that next week when we meet again yep so
just on a closing
note we heard
two big questions right there at the end
how can we actually do it
and it would be awesome if people could
read especially the third paper in the
series and look at the letter framework
that john has lita
that uh john has proposed and there's a
simulation there and it's a scaffold for
a lot of rich discussion so on the how
can we actually do this we want to hear
many perspectives as well as people's
thoughts on the third section of paper
and then the second question what is
money which is of course a fascinating
question for history anthropology game
theory so many different areas converge
on what is money and it's a system in
flux as we see quite literally day to
day depending on how closely you follow
crypto
right
thank you everybody for joining us has
been fantastic awesome discussion so
everybody who's um
watching live thanks so much for
participating and next week in number
21.2 we'll have a follow-up discussion
with you john so thanks again for your
engagement and for really giving us this
foundation with the multiple precursor
videos because it really helped and i
think this is gonna be a great uh
conversation sequence so
peace out everybody
see you later bye thanks bye thanks
bye-bye
[Music]